hey everyone diavolo here and in today's
video we are going to be going over one of
if not my favorite and most definitely flashiest
arc in kamitsu no yuba's story this is the entire
entertainment district arc from the one and only
demon slayer but quickly two seconds before we
get into the video if you do enjoy my content
and want to watch more stuff just like this
then be sure to hit that subscribe button
and also be sure to leave a like on the video
as it really helps out with the algorithm and
pushes my stuff to a bunch of new amazing people
plus extra long videos like these take even longer
to produce so i really do appreciate it but anyway
enough of that let's get into the flashiest arc
in all of demon slayer so four months after the
mugen train incident and the passing of rengoku
all three boys had been relentlessly training
at the butterfly mansion and occasionally going on
missions so that they could improve their strength
tangido says that they're able to endure all
of their training since the boys are together
later after completing one of his solo missions
tanjuro approaches the butterfly mansion to hear
the screams of the young girls inside inside the
property aoi and naho scream to be let go after
the sound hashira tengan uzoi picked them up and
started to take them away while the other girls in
their plea for their freedom aoe calls out to kano
to try and help save them initially hesitant on
what to do kanel makes the decision to chase after
uzoi and she grabs a hold of the girls tengan
looks at kano and tells her to obey her orders
but when she doesn't respond to him he becomes
aggravated and starts to call her a stuck-up pig
the other girls get scared by his screaming but
they all managed to master up their courage to
swarm him and stop him from kidnapping aoe and
naho at this point tanjuro enters the property
and although he initially gets confused as to
what's going on he decides to head butt tengen in
order to free the girls however as he goes to make
contact dengan escapes the head bar flying above
them and revealing that he previously used to be
a ninja tanjiro angrily demands that uzui returns
the girls wakiyo and sumi continuously assault him
with names because of this tengen becomes even
more riled up at their disrespect and he demands
that they obey him as their superior officer
however tangero stubbornly refuses to acknowledge
tengen as his superior causing him to explode
with anger while seeing him with anger tengan
explains that he needs female corpse members in
order to carry out his mission he then states
that since they aren't sukuco he doesn't need
to ask shinobu for permission to take the girls
keo cries out that naho isn't a corpse member so
tengen just tosses her off the roof and decides to
only take aoi still not pleased with the outcome
tangero demands that he gives up aoi and instead
he will go in her place and with almost perfect
timing senetsu and inosuke arrive to help protect
the girls also offering to go on the mission in
place of them uzui ends up giving in and whacks
aoe on the back as he returns it to the girls as
the boys set off on the mission they asked tengan
where exactly they are going to which he says the
flashiest place in japan stepped in lust and ever
ice ultimately revealing that they are heading
towards the one and only entertainment district
before arriving outside the entertainment district
tengen begins instructing the trio and establishes
himself as the leader of the three young demon
slayers he then specifically states his status
as a god and demands that they all bow scrape and
evert their eyes being genuinely intrigued tanjo
falls for the tengan's flamboyance and asks what
it is that uzuwi rules over as a so-called god
sensing the complete absurdity of this scenario
zenitsu concludes that uzui is a bad sign and
is left speechless by just how gullible tanjiro
truly is tengen explains that he is the god of
festivals and upon hearing this inosuki loudly
introduces himself as the god of the mountain
trying to imply that they are both on equal ground
but this disgusts uzui he then instructs the group
to follow him to a wisteria house there they will
discuss their plans then in almost an instant he
sprints off and vanishes leaving the group to
chase after him in a complete panic once they
arrive at the wisteria house tengan asks the group
to be on a lookout for a young lady he could marry
which infuriates zenitsu he angrily tells tengen
to stop screwing around and stop using members of
the corpse to be his matchmakers tengan blows up
and yells that he doesn't need a matchmaker since
he's already married and that they're searching
for his wives who have failed to respond to his
letters zenitsu who doesn't believe it tells
tenkan to stop spreading his fantasies causing
tenkin to angrily whack him in the face with a
pile of letters tanjuro begins to sift through
all of the letters noticing the large quantity he
comments that she must have been a fast writer to
which tenkan clarifies that the large quantity
is due to the fact that he has three wives after
hearing this zenitsu's head erupts and fills with
rage thinking that the tenkan is lying he demands
to know how he could possibly have three wives
tenkin gets angry at his remarks and punches
zenitsu in his stomach with such force that
it renders him completely unconscious tangible
begins to ask how they plan on sneaking into the
district leaving their tengan to explain that they
will be disguised his wives whichakunuichi were
originally stationed there after he himself failed
to find any leads as a customer but after they
narrowed down a few possible locations of where
the demon might be they lost all communication
overhearing the situation anoski bruntly asks
what if his wives are already dead to which
tengan also punches them in the stomach knocking
him unconscious as well within the entertainment
district a majority of the workers are individuals
who were sold into the business due to poverty and
deaths as a courtesan their job is to appeal and
entertain customers so they can eventually find
a wealthy man who is willing to buy their freedom
the highest classification of a courtesan is an
orion who is considered to be the most artistic
beautiful and educated and is thus only ever
reserved for the wealthiest of customers as the
group finally arrives tengan uses his charming
looks to give away the boys who were disguised
as girls and is initially successfully able to
give tanjido away to their takito house thinking
then proceeds down the street with the other two
boys following behind anosuke and uzoi notice a
courtesan procession coming towards them on this
tree and learned that the aurian named konowatsu
is on her way to greet asuto zenitsu notices the
orion and angrily yells tengan demanding to know
if that's his wife as well which ends up earning
him another punch in the face a woman approaches
tengen and asks him if he is looking for a house
and offers to take inosuke into the ogimoto house
to which tengen accepts standing there alone
zinetsu fearfully starts to realize that he
is the only one left with the hashira skipping
over to the ogimoto house where two women are
clapping for joy at just how beautiful enosuke is
after removing her makeup due to this they become
motivated to educate him and transform him to
become the most popular orion within the district
meanwhile in the kyogoku house zenitsu is in the
middle of putting on an emotional performance with
a shamasian after being abandoned by tengan uzui
and at the tokito house tangido is assisting in
doing household chores the staff asks tanjiro to
carry the orion's belongings up to her room which
he does so happily when he arrives at the room
he discovers two young girls gossiping inside
and overhears them talking about ashanuke confused
tanjiro asks what it is the girls explain that
ashinoke is when a courtesan runs off with a
customer without paying off their debts they
also mention a rumor that suma the most recent
courtesan had run away which catches tanjiru's
attention just then koenatsu walks into the room
and tells the girls to stop gossiping and thanks
tanjuro for carrying up her belongings she gives
him a piece of candy to express her gratitude and
tanjiru decides to ask her if the rumor regarding
soma was true or not koenigsu looks stunned by the
sudden question and asks him why exactly he's
asking her tangido panics and lies telling her
that suma is his older sister but due to sanjido
being unable to lie he pulls a sour face and ends
up frightening all of the girls koenatsu again
questions tanjido if he was sold into the house
just like his sister causing him to again
uncomfortably lie that he was in fact sold and was
exchanging letters with suma koinatu reluctantly
tells tangido that she does not believe suma would
run away however when they discovered her diary in
her desk she had written that she was planning on
running away she also reveals that there has been
no information regarding if she hasn't managed
to escape or not tanjiru begins to speculate
that it could be the demon that was creating
the facade that sumer had run away and might
possibly be responsible for implanting the diary
he then prays for her safety and promises to
himself that he will find a way to help her
at a similar time in the district tengen is seen
on the top of a roof watching the activity of the
public he fails to notice any unusual activity
and can't help but have a bad feeling on the
lack of action and proceeds to speculate that the
demon must be strong due to its ability to hide
its presence back at the okimoto house enosuke is
starting to investigate the whereabouts of makio
and overhears two women conversing in front of
makio's room the woman begins to gossip that
makio was feeling unwell and had not left her room
for the entire day anosuke begins to speculate
on the information and proceeds down the hall
however he becomes infuriated at having to wear
the uncomfortable kinemon during the hot weather
and recalls tengan's threats before the boys had
separated tenkin had threatened him not to
strip down or speak due to his deep voice
making it harder for inosuke to gather information
inside makio's room an ominous voice is seen
questioning a woman who she was sending letters
to a large obi-like demon is then seen holding
the woman hostage the demon calls the woman by
her name revealing the hostage to be makio while
being held hostage by the ob demon makio tries
to formulate a plan to try to escape however the
demon senses inosuke snooping in the hallway and
decides to make an escape itself inosuke senses
the change in the atmosphere and rushes into the
room he discovers the room is destroyed and senses
the demon is hiding in the ceiling as the demon
tries to escape inosuke begins to give chase and
rushes down the hallway as he prepares to turn
down the hallway he decides to punch a hole in
the wall in order to pull the demon out however
when he swings a customer comes into the clearing
and unknowingly gets punched into the wall the
staff look in horror as zanowski looks around to
try and find the demon but to his frustration
he loses size of it and blames the customer
over at the kyogoku house zinetsu calms down after
his emotional performance and begins to search for
hinatsuru due to the fact that the staff had
been mourning the manager's death he's had
trouble collecting any information on her possible
whereabouts so far susanetsu decides to use his
advanced sense of hearing in order to listen to
try and find any information on what's going on
in doing so he overhears a girl quietly sobbing
and rushes to try and find her when he arrives he
discovers the room is completely destroyed and
the girl is disheveled in the middle of it he
approaches her but she begins to sob again causing
zinitsu to frantically try to comfort her as
he's kneeling on the ground zenitsu suddenly gets
chills and sends the sunning approach from behind
him the orion of the house warabahime glares down
at him and coldly demands what business he has
in her room without turning around zinetsu
recognizes the sound that she is giving off
is not human and realizes that she is the demon
that the four slayers have been searching for
wada bahime angrily repeats her question after
zinezu fails to respond and the other girls of the
house explain that zenitsu is news of the house
zenitsu attempts to apologize and explain that he
was checking on the girl but this angers wadahime
who rudely calls in itsu ugly and creepy leaving
him shocked wadahime looks around to see that
the room is still in a mess and pulls the girl
who was crying by the air causing her to yell in
pain the girl apologizes for failing to clean the
room but wada bahime continues to harm the girl
causing her to yell out in agony unable to put
up with the abuse zenitsu grabs whatever he may
by the arm demanding that she let go of the girl
skipping back two nights before the demon
slayers arrived at the entertainment district
the manager of the kyogoku house omitsu holds
a meeting with the orion of her household she
explains to wada boheme that she has to restrain
herself from bullying the other courtesans of the
house to which wada bahime feigns her innocence
amitsu expresses her frustration at having ignored
her behaviour explaining that she has gone too
far but wada boheme guilts her by mentioning
that she brings money into the household
omitsu becomes nervous as she mentions a tale
she heard from an elder when she was just a
child she explains that the elder had recalled
a courtesan who was extremely beautiful but had
a rotten personality the courtesan was the orient
of their household and had been around since
the elder was a child and was eerily similar to
the ori and the elder saw when she was an adult
coincidentally the orien's names both ended in
heimei and had a nasty glare when they were both
displeased as omitsu continues talking she notices
the similarities between the elders description
and wada beheme however before she questions the
fidelity of her race wada bahime transforms into
her original appearance as [ __ ] and pulls omitsu
from the house as they fly up into the night sky
[ __ ] eerily remarks that the people around her
had managed to survive by remaining silent on the
atrocities that they've witnessed until tonight
omitsu fearfully brandishes a knife revealing
her intention to kill daki however she berates
omitsu for being more stupid than she believed
and bids her goodbye dropping her to her death
daki nonchalantly lands on a nearby rooftop and
struts away as the citizens discover omitsu dead
on the ground when she returns to her room daki
discovers muzan awaiting and humbly greets him
muzan comments on her appearance and speculates
that she's eating a large amount of humans
he proudly congratulates her and cautions her to
not act recklessly [ __ ] complies and receives
information regarding the possible arrival of the
demon slayers she is encouraged by muzan to become
even stronger and crueler than she was before
the flashback ends and rolls into the situation
with zinitsu confronting whatabahime she becomes
angry and slams him into the wall rendering him
completely unconscious she openly voices
her disgust and demands that he never touch
her again and also scarily remarks that she will
administer harshu discipline the commotion causes
amitsu's husband to rush over and apologize for
zenko's actions he begs her to forgive him as they
prepare for the customers suddenly wada bahime
has a sudden change of character and apologizes
to the manager while he quickly orders for her
room to be cleaned as watabahime leaves the room
she has her doubts about zinetsu and realizes
that he isn't any ordinary human and might
actually be a member of the demon slayers
in her clean room she can be seen ominously
laughing to herself as she openly welcomes the
idea of demon slayers arriving in the district
promising she'll eat all of them outside tangier
waits looking into the night sky feeling uneasy
as he comments on the dark and musky smell
that has taken the town with the manager
being informed of zenko's sudden disappearance
from the kyogoku house the staff member explains
to him that she had disappeared after being left
to rest in her room however the mention of zenko
angers the manager and he tells the staff member
to forget all about zenko the manager chases her
out before expressing his frustration at
having to submit to wada bahime's desires
elsewhere on the rooftop inosuke can be seen
explaining the demon he saw in the ogimoto house
tanjuro his exotic description and excitement
worries tajiro and he tells him to calm down until
tengen and zenitsu arrive for the meeting tenkan
stealthily and flashily arrives undetected
and proclaims that sinitsu will not be arriving he
also mentions that he might have put the boys in
immediate danger tenkan tells inosuke and tanjiro
that they must leave the district before the upper
ranked demon makes their move and announces that
he will be continuing the mission alone tangero
tries to argue against his decision however
tengen quickly leaves as fast as he arrived
tanju begins to wonder if they are trustworthy due
to being members of the lowest demon slayer rank
but inosuka interrupts to inform them that they've
climbed their ranks a fair birth and he flexes
his hand out and shows tanjido the kano rank which
appears and tells them their status in the ranking
confused about the revelation inosuke
explains to tanchito they're following the
final selections their hands were marked with
the wisteria flower and grey theme tangero is
left slightly embarrassed and not knowing how to
check but anoscape promptly tells him to cheer up
tangero gets back on track and tells inosuke that
he will meet with him outside the ogimoto house
once night falls claiming that he wants to finish
investigating the tokito house before he leaves
which angers inosuke he punches tajiro by
the cheek and tells him to follow him at that
moment but tanju explains that there might
be a secret passage beneath the household
that might lead to the demon he tells inosuke
that he thinks the tengen's wives are still alive
as well as zenitsu and he asks him to comply in
order to save them successfully anosuke smiles
and lets tanjuno know that he was thinking
the exact same thing and agrees to the plan
back at the tokiso house koenatsu has finished
with her preparations and is visited by tanjuro
he arrives without his disguise and informs
koenatsu that he is leaving the house and
asks her to pass on his payment for his meals
he's had she asks why he's dressed that way
and tanjudo explains that he's actually a boy
while apologizing to her but to her this was no
surprise as she claims that she knew all along and
wondered what he was up to he tells her that he
hopes to save the individuals who have disappeared
from the house and she expresses her relief while
also saying that she'll be leaving as well they
wish each other well and say their goodbyes before
tanjulo leaves the room but when koenatsu hears a
sound she turns around to discover [ __ ] standing
right behind her as tanjoro hurries off he
catches the faint smell of the upper ranked demon
at the okamoto house enosuke can be seen
complaining as he waits for tanjiro to arrive
since the time to meet was long overdue onoski
became fed up and decides to begin the mission
alone he jumps with such force that he bursts
through the ceiling and calls for the mice to
bring his swords these mice are team conservants
who had been especially trained to act on missions
as an oscar begins to change and make his leave a
member of the staff can be seen with a horrified
expression as she sees anosuke with a boar's mask
over at the kyogoku house omitsu's husband is seen
holding a kimono in his hand in just a moment
tengan appears in the room and holds a kunai to
his throat demanding to know the whereabouts of
hinatsuru and zenko the man quickly reveals that
zenko had suddenly disappeared and that hinatsuru
was sick therefore she went to a low end brothel
tengan questions the man further and asks
who he thinks is responsible for causing the
trouble within the house however the man begins
to hyperventilate but tengan reassures him that
he can be trusted and he will exact revenge on
the individual responsible the man envisions his
deceased wife and informs tengen that it's wada
bahime who's causing the problems he also informs
him that she has the north room where the sunlight
never falls the man stops talking for a moment
and quickly turns around however by that point
tengan had already left the man is left alone
in the room holding his wife's bloody kimono when
the tengan arrives to watahime's room he discovers
that the demon is not there and she is probably
out hunting he quickly leaves the search for
hinatsuru and swears that he will return to defeat
the demon with his own hands elsewhere tangido has
discovered [ __ ] within kawanatu's room as she
attempts to kidnap her within her obi daki informs
tanjiro that she will not be eating him since
he is dirty and old meaning that only a hashera
will suffice her appetite tangero yells at her
to release koenatsu however his demands irritate
[ __ ] as she lashes out throwing him from the
building tangido is left stunned from her immense
speed and power but he manages to regain his
composure and stands back up on his feet he begins
to analyze the situation and realizes that her obi
has a special power that can swallow people whole
at that moment [ __ ] climbs out of the window
and is amazed that tangier was still alive
tanju apologizes to nezuko after realising that
one of the shoulder straps is broken on the box
he tells her that he has to leave her here for now
and warns her not to come out of the box unless
her life is in utter danger he initiates his
attack against daki by using his water-breathing
fourth form striking tide turbulent to attempt to
slash atu obi he successfully manages to perform
an aerial attack against daki and slices the
end of the ob that was holding koinatu captive
dhaki states that tanjido is cute but he makes her
sick and compares him to a dying rat before saying
that she likes him as well after arriving at one
of the keremese houses tengan is seen caring for
his wife hinatsuru she tells him to leave her to
go investigate the loud sounds that were heard
within the district but before he can do so she
apologizes to him for failing to complete the
mission when she initially arrived at yoshiwara
hinatsuru was placed in the kyogoku house to
investigate she realized that wada bahime was
the demon but could not make any hasty decisions
in an attempt to escape and avoid suspicion
hinatsuru drunk poison and pretended to fall ill
however she was gifted an obi by the orient to spy
on her and ultimately kill her if she did anything
suspicious tengen comforts henatsuru and tells
her she did well during the mission revealing the
defeated obi in the background he advises her to
leave the district as soon as the antidote takes
effect to which she agrees as they embrace as
tengen leaves the house and heads back towards the
battlefield he tries to listen for the sounds of
the demon and hears the vibration coming through
an underground cavern he pulls out his blades
and uses his sound breathing first form roar to
slam onto the ground causing a large explosion
which can be heard by [ __ ] in the distance
she questions tangero as to how many demon slayers
are in the district but he refuses to tell her
she tries to strike a deal with him that if he
answers her question she will spare him while
simultaneously trying to intimidate him he begins
to discredit his ability to perform the water
breathing compared to sakonji and geyu atangido
mentions that he needs to rely on the hinukami
kagura in order to land powerful blows but he
lacks the ability to perform multiple strikes
with her tanjuro tries to regain his focus and
encourages himself that all of his training should
pay off he mentally envisions keojiro's voice
telling him to keep his heart burning and manages
to perform the hinokami kagura raging sun to
block darki's obi daki notices the change in his
fighting style as tanjo cuts off a large section
of her obi as she tries to analyze this change
tanjo suddenly bursts towards her he swings his
blade down using hinukami kagura flame dance to
try and decapitate her but she narrowly avoids it
as tanjaro tries to attack her again [ __ ] gains
the upper hand and tries to decapitate tangido
with her obi however tangio utilizes another
hinokami kagura fake rainbow to escape [ __ ]
is left confused trying to locate where tanjulo
has disappeared to but within seconds tanjiro
appears behind her and uses hinokami kagura
firewheel to attack her once again tangido's
blade makes contact with the neck of [ __ ] badaki
manages to quickly deflect tangero's attack and
sends him flying into the ground he tries to
continue his attack however he's left exhausted
from his use of hinokami kagura and has trouble
getting up as daki quickly approaches tanjido
manages to use the recovery breathing technique to
overcome his technique and narrowly avoids darki's
attack tanjuno goes on the offensive and attacks
[ __ ] however her obi gets in the way preventing
him from defeating her leaving him with no choice
but to raise his body temperature even higher
tangible recalls an interaction he had with keo
at the butterfly mansion she begins to worry over
tanjuro's uncontrollable fever and tells him that
she needs to inform shinobu tanjuro tries to
reassure her that he's fine and not to tell
shinobu however kyo mentions that his fever has
been at 100.4 degrees for over several days now
and it could mean that something is terribly wrong
he confesses to her that he has been training with
the hinokami kagura in order to improve his
skills and begs her to hold on a bit before
reporting to the shinobu here reluctantly agrees
but tells him that she will only wait for a birth
back in the battle against daki tanju begins
to gasp as the hinokami kagura begins to take
a toll on his body but he refuses to lead up
in order to protect the people in the district
he uses his determination to promise that
he won't allow daki to take another life
and cause the people to go through the
sadness he and his comrades had to experience
his breath fumes out from his mouth as he prepares
to attack dhaki yet again flashing back to earlier
at the ogimoto house a member of staff frantically
approaches the other woman as she claims to have
seen a monster the other woman are left confused
at the woman's unusual claims as she explains that
she saw a boar monster destroying the ceiling and
the floor elsewhere in the house in oscar can be
seen cackling as he discovers a hole leading to
the demon's nest he proudly yells at the hole
to prepare itself before trying to dive in head
first after realizing that only his head fits
he takes it as a challenge and begins to snap his
body claiming that he can dislocate all joints of
his entire body all the while frightening the
life out of his staff they seem to be observing
him while he's doing this he manages to somehow
slither through the opening and travels down
through the tunnel until he reaches a main
cavern area once he arrives he discovers
the long trails of the obi draped throughout the
entire cavern as he takes a closer look he can see
multiple people being held captive within the
obi and discovers zenitsu knocked out among them
as well anosuke becomes disgusted with the worm
like obi and begins his assault against the obi
by slicing sections of it off while simultaneously
assaulting it with words the women who were held
captive begin to slip out from these sections
causing the ob to panic at the situation around it
the obi analyzes inosuke's natural abilities and
has trouble formulating a plan however darky's
consciousness takes control as she orders the obi
to capture him alive azinosuke prepares to slice
another section of the ob it suddenly becomes more
elastic and folds along inosuke's blade before the
obi can attack him though inosuke gains the upper
hand by maneuvering to perform beast breathing
sixth fang palaside bite however the obi manages
to distract him the obi mentions inosuke's failure
at protecting the individuals he's freed claiming
that it can just easily swallow them all up whole
again it proceeds to move towards the unconscious
individuals however a kunai flies out of nowhere
causing the obi to react two women appear holding
kunai and agree with anosuke's description
of the worm like obi and begin to attack it they
explained to inosuke that they are there to help
him and will protect the others from the ob anoski
reluctantly agrees but then he asks them who they
are to which they reveal that they're the tengan's
missing wives suma and makio makio begins to scold
sumer who sulks after revealing that she was the
first one who was captured she also begins to cry
as she realizes that they can't help everyone and
are most likely going to die the obi seems pleased
by summer's pessimistic attitude and questions
who should get eaten first but before it can get
the chance to attack zenetsu quickly attacks the
ob amazed by his skill enosuke comments that he
probably shouldn't wake zenetsu up and summa and
makio question this man's identity the ob is left
amazed by zenitsu's speed but tries to understand
the sounds it heard it specifically mentions
that there were two sounds like thunder one came
from zinetsu but when the obi finally recognizes
the source of the second sound the ceiling
explodes and breaks down suma looks up into
the distance and a silhouette can be seen from
the individual who's dropped down into the hole
tengan brandishes his blades as he takes a deep
breath and within seconds slashes the obi within
his vicinity makio turns around and calls out
to tenkan who apologizes for taking too long
he then promises that things are about to get real
flashy going back to makio as a young adult she
lived the lifestyle of a kunuichi and was often
taught to survive instead of trying to accomplish
the mission these ideals were again reiterated
into her mindset when she married tengen
who would tell his wives to always prioritize
their lives and return to him he would make sure
to let them know that he would take responsibility
to protect the public after protecting them mahia
would often question if his morals were right
or not however hinotsuru would reassure her
that wanting to live was not immoral back in the
cavern tengan greets his wives by passing them on
the head and compliments that they've put in great
work inosuke calls out to the god of festivals and
gets mad at him for allowing the obi to escape
but tengan loses his temper and defends his wives
saying that they save the people that were trapped
makio interrupts him to say that they need to
leave immediately before things get worse he then
quickly instructs everyone to follow him now up on
the rooftop tengan sprints towards the battlefield
and inosuke and zinitsu struggle to catch up with
him in the middle of the battle between daki and
tanjuro the oh becomes flying and unexpectedly
enters darkie's body tanjuro realizes that the ob
is entering darky's main body and tries to attack
her but she quickly disappears she then reappears
on a nearby rooftop as her hair turns white she
squeals with delight as she learns there's a
hush era within the district at that moment a
bystander discovers tanjudo acting suspiciously
on the street and tells him to stop fighting in
front of his shop ducky overhears the man and
becomes enraged by his comment she lashes out a
flurry of attacks on the buildings around her and
ends up cutting off the man's arm and the process
she also manages to kill other bystanders in
nearby houses destroying them all as well tangido
sees the bloodshed nearby and tells the man to tie
turnika around his arm despite bleeding heavily
himself daki begins to walk away after destroying
the houses but tanjido tells her that he will not
allow her to get away with this [ __ ] cockingly
tells him to stop speaking to her since an ugly
human's life has no value and he is just another
rotten corpse hearing this and seeing the damage
that she has caused around him tangero's heart
begins to beat louder and louder and his eyes
start to fill with rage tanjulo recalls a letter
that was addressed to him by shinjuro ringoku who
admits that he wronged him in the letter he thanks
him for mourning kyogido's death as well as for
befriending sengioro and proceeds to express his
embarrassment for his behavior when they first met
he explained that he was wallowing in sorrow
over the death of his wife and incompetence as
a hashira that he turned to alcohol despite his
lack of presence as a father kiyojiro had proved
himself to be a better son he was managing
to become a how sharer even though shinjiro
had refused to continue teaching him shinjuru
writes in his letters that tangier was gifted
with a power and is destined for greatness as
seen from the demon slayer mark he was born with
however tangiero clarifies that shinjuro is
wrong because he wasn't born with the mark he
recalls guessing the mark when he was protecting
his younger brother from a falling brazier and
then it changed his appearance during the final
selection unlike his father who was born with the
mark sanjido simply acquired it meaning he wasn't
a chosen one nonetheless he refuses to back down
back in the fight as [ __ ] walks away from
tanjuro he quickly grabs her and narrowly
tries to cut her neck but she manages to avoid
the attack and move away from him she loses her
foot in the process but her regeneration skills
allow her to develop a new one within seconds
tanjuno notices her regeneration and asks daki
why she steals people's lives and ruins them
his tone of voice comes off as familiar tadaki
as she envisions a different swordsman before her
although she doesn't recognize the swordsman [ __
] realizes that she's envisioning muzan's memories
tangero continues to question her reasoning and
taunts her with the fact that she was once a human
who endured hardships as well [ __ ] proceeds
to glorify the privileges of being a demon
seemingly mocking the circumstances that humans
face her confidence grows as [ __ ] believes that
she is now untouchable due to the fact that
she has returned back to her original form
she bids tangero farewell and begins
to think about going after the hashira
however tanjo utilizes the hinokami kagura burning
bones summer sun to burn the obi blocking his path
ducky is left stunned by her wounds and inability
to regenerate to the point where she begins to
shake and is left to defend herself from tangier's
flurry of attacks he closes in and swings his
blade to decapitate her but she continues to
resist as her neck transforms into an obi refusing
to be cut tangible's blade begins struggling as
it tries to cut through darky's obi-like neck
the resisting cloth forces tangero to abandon
his attack and escape before daki has the
chance to fight back however when he tries to
recollect his thoughts [ __ ] charges towards him
and tries to slash him tanjulo analyzes her
movements and has realised that he can see her
in slow motion giving him the advantage as her
wild obi attacks him from multiple directions
tanjuno manages to pin them all in a
single spot and proceeds to charge at her
while cutting away the obi his flames burn the
obi away within seconds as he comes to a close
proximity to daki however just when he's about
to decapitate her tanju envisions his sister
hanako desperately begging his brother to breathe
in that moment tangero loses his focus and begins
gasping for air after nearly passing his physical
limitations he collapses onto the ground finally
feeling the pain that he has been suppressing
and his eyes begin to bleed it is revealed
that he has been acting on hunger and has been
using his life force to surpass his limitations
however his sister was able to warn him before
he could sustain any life-threatening damage
daki glares down at tanjido and berates him for
his weaknesses as a human she mocks his injuries
and slowly approaches him to deliver the final
blow before she can deliver the attack a leg comes
down and kicks [ __ ] behind rupturing her head
nisiko can be seen boiling with rage as she stands
between tajido who's struggling to breathe on the
ground and [ __ ] nezuko recalls the memories of
when her family was slaughtered on a snowy night
and her rage grows stronger as she prepares to
fight the upper ranked demon darky's head and
face begin to regenerate as she glares holes
into nezuko she recognizes her as the demon muzan
specifically had told her about nezuko's face
begins to transform as her infinite anger begins
to push her forward leaving everyone wondering
what would happen in niziko's case as she also
gained the ability to have no physical limitations
flashing back to just before when muzan
arrived at the kyogoku house to see daki
there he had told her to find the demon who had
escaped his grasp just like tamiyo he identifies
her as having a hemp like pasu and kimono as well
as a checkerboard obi and tells daki that she is
his last hope to catch nezuko flashing forward now
in the present [ __ ] promises that she will kill
neziko and lay her down at muzan's feet as proof
of this nisiko faces [ __ ] and charges to once
again try to kick off darky's head however [ __
] is able to cut off nezuko's leg using her obi
while niziko looks down at her bleeding thigh [ __
] uses the opportunity to knock her off the roof
and blast her into a nearby building as the two
demons are fighting tangero falls unconscious
and envisions his brother takio in his dream
takio mentions how tanjuno and nezuko are very
alike when they're kind and angry and goes on to
recall an instance when he saw naziko get angry
he explains how fearful he was when he saw her and
was worried about her lack of concern for herself
mentioning that within an instant she
could have lost everything that she holds
dear back in the fight [ __ ] jumps down from
the rooftop and approaches neziko who's trapped
underneath a pile of rubble she mocks her
for being weak and a half developed demon
daki continues to provoke her and cockingly says
that she will not fight nezuko anymore and will
simply leave her trapped and expose her to the
sunlight instead however before [ __ ] can say
anything else neziko comes out from the rubble
and regenerates her leg in an instant leaving
[ __ ] stunned at her abilities nezuko proceeds to
instantaneously regenerate her arm which was cut
off as well leaving [ __ ] uneasy as she realizes
that her regenerative abilities are on par with
an upper-ranked demon nezuko's body transforms
as she breaks her bamboo muzzle and a horn grows
out the right side of her forehead and her body
also becomes covered in ivy like demon crests
[ __ ] gets more intimidated by nezuko's change
in aura as she tries to defend herself from one of
her kicks stressfully cutting it off with her ob
however before she can cut nezuko's head [ __ ] is
smashed to the ground by nezuko's kick [ __ ] is
left shocked as niziko's leg passes through her
body pinning her onto the ground she tries to make
sense of how niziko could attack her with the legs
she had just sliced off but then realizes that
nezuko had instantly regenerated the leg within
that moment admitting that nezuko's regenerative
abilities are greater than her own nesigo begins
to become manic following her transformation as
tanjudo still remains in his unconscious state
takeo desperately taps him on his back begging
for him to help he tells tangido to please wake
up and help niziko who isn't acting like herself
anymore forcing tanjuro to awake with concern as
this happens [ __ ] remains pinned on the ground
and she tries to use her obi to free herself from
nezuko's hold her obi effectively severes multiple
limbs from nezuko's body but before she gets the
chance to scoop them up nezuko's severed hands
grip onto her obi her limbs remain connected by
who unusually solidified blood was some of the
blood falling onto [ __ ] in an instant dark
is set on fire by the blood causing her to scream
out in agony mizuko's limbs wind back to reattach
to her body and they self-cauterize each cart she
proceeds to forcefully stomp down on darkie's head
causing it to erupt in flames niziko continues
to stomp multiple times on her head before she
forcefully kicks [ __ ] through a nearby building
and into one behind it as she follows [ __ ] to
continue her assault nezuko comes across an
injured woman who stares at nezuko with fear as
she tends to her bleeding wound nesco falls into a
trance and charges into the home towards the woman
as she fails to suppress her hunger for blood out
of nowhere though tangero jumps on top of neziko
and uses his blade to act as a muzzle in order to
restrain her he yells at her to fight the hunger
and encourages her to be strong but she lashes
out at him and scratches him on the face trying to
escape he apologizes to her for making her fight
after smelling the blood that spilled from her
injuries he proceeds to reassure her that her big
brother is now there to protect her and that she
can now heal herself nezuko manages to regain her
footing and she jumps through the ceiling with
tanjuro on her back causing an intense amount
of damage to happen to the building as tanjulo
struggles to restrain his sister the walls of the
room are seemingly slashed as [ __ ] barges into
the room with her burned face she is seen seething
with anger as she is forced to regenerate her
burned body and angrily approaches the siblings
tangerine becomes conflicted on what to do
as he realizes that there are bystanders he needs
to protect but he also needs to defend dhaki's
attacks without releasing nezuko as tanjido makes
his decision to protect the public tangent ozoe
suddenly appears before him and expresses
his surprise in nezuko's flashy demonization
tengu goes on to comically berate tangido for
speaking highly of nezuko's ability to restrain
herself back at the ubishiki estate despite him
struggling to restrain her now daki sees tengen
and excitedly reacts to ahashira arriving before
her but is quickly and chillingly told to shut her
tenkin tells her to scram and says that she is too
weak to be an upper ranked demon all of a sudden
darky's head which had just been decapitated as
tengan flew past fell into her lap leaving her
completely stunned and simply confused at what
had just transpired tangier was left shocked by
tengan's swift victory over daki but the sound
to shira reminds him that the fight isn't over
as his sister is still out of control tangero
struggles to restrain her with tengan suggesting
to sing her a lullaby to put her to sleep but at
that moment nezuko regains her footing and jumps
out of another building window taking her brother
with her again as they continue the struggle
realising his words aren't reaching her tanju asks
his mother in a dreamlike state what he should do
he then remembers tengen's earlier advice to sing
nezuko a lullaby he begins to sing her a song that
their mother had sung in the past and over a short
period of time his lullaby soon reaches her nezuko
remembers asking their mother about the song
when she was a child causing her to break down
in tears niziko comes to her senses and changes
from her advanced demonized form into her regular
childlike state promptly falling asleep tanjulo
lets out a relieved sigh as he successfully holds
an isako in his lap back in the house daki
screams attengan for cutting her head off
and he responds by telling her to die quietly the
enraged demon reminds him he had denied her upper
rank status which he affirms but she proceeds
to insist her status much to his annoyance
to the hashera's astonishment daki begins
to throw attention and cry and he notes
that she's been taking far too long for when she
should have been showing signs of dying by now
still throwing her tantrum daki calls out to
guatara to save her and a male demon begins to
emerge from her body tengan senses the danger
and attempts to immediately attack the two
but his blades hit nothing by ear as the demon
disappears from his sight tengan wonders why
[ __ ] is still alive after being beheaded as well
as the presence of the new demon who he comments
is having a great reaction speed guyotaro tells
daki to heal her burn complementing her good looks
and he then wounds tengan when he attempts to
try and attack them again guatara complements
tengan's attempt to attack him as well as his
success at blocking his attack he reveals that
he was intending to kill tenkan with that attack
and prepares to take him on in a battle within the
entertainment district there are men known as goos
or barkers who work to attract customers to enter
the brothels guataru worked as one of these men
and eventually named himself using the word goo
inside one of the brothels gyotato and tengan are
about to engage in combat but before they do so
gotaro begins to analyze tengan's appearance
he comments about his nice face good skin
and height mentioning that he must attract a
lot of attention from woman guitar begins to
creepily scratch at his face until he begins to
bleed and voices his jealousy over tengen's looks
in the corner of the room [ __ ] can be seen
crying as she whines at guitar to kill the other
demon slayers who burned her as well she proceeds
to tell him that they ganged up on her and she
tried her hardest to kill them causing guatara
to seethe with anger using two large sickles he
creates a flurry of large arc-like slashes aiming
them towards tengen tanjulo can be seen carrying
niziko as he rushes to put her to safety he looks
up into the sky and sees the sickles return back
in the direction that they came like a boomerang
he becomes concerned when he smells tengen's blood
and rushes to return to help at that moment
inosuke and zinitsu can be seen flinging
towards tanjuro as they awkwardly announce their
arrival tanjo quickly informs them to help tengan
and inosuke ensures him that he's going to be
real flashy before quickly leaving tangido to
put nezuko in her box back at the parlor guataro
seeds with jealousy after witnessing how cool
tenkan looks by protecting the bystanders within
the home causing him to brag about his appearance
and marriage to the three woman gurotaro pauses an
astonishment before furiously scratching his face
after hearing tengan's polygamy he proceeds to use
his blood demon art flying bloodsicle to try and
kill the hashera but tengan manages to block it a
large explosion causes the floor beneath tengan to
give in and he manages to escape by dropping down
one floor however guatara commands his sickles
to turn and they come straight for tengan yet
again by this point tengen had realized guitar's
abilities to change the sickles and the directions
that he wants and tries to formulate a plan on how
we will try and defeat these siblings he theorizes
that in order to kill the demons he would need
to cut off guataro's head instead of darky's head
and tries to test it out dengen grabs three small
balls and throws them into the air he proceeds to
aim for them and precisely hits them to cause an
explosion within the brothel as the brothel begins
to crumble tenkin is seen standing on the rubble
as he admits it won't be easy to defeat the demons
he looks at the large obi ball before him and
the siblings emerge unscathed as they confidently
proclaim that they fight as one after successfully
finding the box and placing nezuko inside tangier
quickly tries to return to the battlefield in
order to assist uzui while this happens at the
battlefield gyrotaro scouts as he mentions tenka's
supreme abilities calling him different and
talented compared to the other hashiro he's killed
his comments somewhat irritate tenkan and he
berates him for thinking that he's talented
compared to the other people on the planet calling
him ignorance he grows more and more angry as he
recalls the people that he's lost over the years
despite being called the chosen one by guataro
after listening to him speak guru taro grows
irritated by the fact that he has not died yet
revealing that his poison drenched sickle should
have killed him by now tengan explains that he
is a built up resistance to poison as he was
raised in a shinobi household with nine siblings
but by the age of 15 seven of them had already
died his father was a cold heartless individual
who would regularly force them to undergo intense
training and as a result his brother adopted the
same ruthlessness and cold-hearted personality
unable to understand that type of mindset tenkin
left his clan alongside his wives and approached
kaguya yubishiki to become members of the corpse
kagaya had warned them it would be hard to reject
the values they were raised in but openly welcomed
them and thanked tengan's family for deciding to
put their lives at the risk to protect others in
the present guatara notices the deterioration in
tenkan's physical state and becomes gleeful when
he realizes that his poison is slowly taking
effect tinker proceeds to refute his claims
saying that he is still in pristine condition and
charges forward to attack the siblings as they
engage in a battle tenkin manages to kick [ __ ]
away from guitar and releases numerous dark bees
which cause a cluster of explosions by setting a
distraction tengen attempts to decapitate guataro
while only holding the tip of the end of one of
his blades but it is promptly blocked by the demon
as both sides reassess the situation [ __ ] is
left whining as she pathetically reattaches her
head to her body once again guataro comforts
tengan about discovering the method on how to
defeat them but he feigns his innocence pretending
not to notice despite tengen's discovery guataro
cockingly says they despite knowing their weakness
tinker will still die from the poisoning since
the demons have the advantage in battle at that
moment zenitsu and enosuke arrive to question the
fidelity of guatara's claim that they are going
to win the two boys flamboyantly announce their
arrival to the fight which confuses everyone at
their moment but then tanjudo drops down from the
ceiling above them and stands between the injured
tengan and the demons preparing to fight makio and
sumer can be seen frantically trying to evacuate
the citizens of the district as the battle resumes
against the demons gyotaro tries to discourage
the three new arrivals and manages to intimidate
tanjiro however tengen uzui comes up behind them
and proudly announces that they are going to win
as daki finishes reattaching her head she loudly
doubts his words by saying that they can't win
since the hashera has been poisoned unfazed tengan
once again proudly announces their intent to win
and speaks highly of the three boys looking
back at him tangible sees the persona of kyogiro
ringoku emitting from tengen as he speaks which
excites inosuke gyotoro and daki get riled up
and reveal that they've eaten 15 and seven hashira
respectively and begin to attack the group as daki
attempts to attack tenkan and tanjiro from behind
zenitsu bursts through the home within seconds to
block the attack and ernosuke follows up now on
the rooftop darki finally recognizes zinitsu from
the kyogoku house and he demandingly commands her
to apologize to the girl whom he had found crying
earlier she mocks his speech by revealing that
the woman are treated like merchandise within
the district and as the orion she was allowed
to do what she pleased with the other people
since she was the main breadwinner of the
house when she looks up at zunitsu a third eye
appears on darky's forehead revealing that guitar
can see them via her eye now back at the brothel
tangero becomes intimidated by guatara's evil aura
but formulates a plan to counteract his attacks
and protect tengen however the demon manages to
rush towards tanchiro within an instant and catch
him off guard narrowly passing him through his jaw
before he can do so tenkin grabs a hold of tangero
by the nape of his clothes and throws him to
safety before engaging in the battle with guataro
as he crash lands and looks back to see the
two fighting tangero senses an ominous object
approaching them from above and darky's obi
can be seen crashing down on all around them
on the rooftop [ __ ] can be heard cackling
as she admits she is now displaying her full
strength since guatara is awake and allowing her
to use his advanced senses zenetsu and enosuke
can be seen covered in cuts and wounds as they
prepare to engage with [ __ ] in battle guwataru
disregards the claims that tenkan made earlier of
the boys being suguko and tries to undermine their
capabilities as swordmen the four demon slayers
can be seen engaging in battle with the two demons
of the entertainment district fighting ferociously
on the rooftop and inside one of the brothels
as the building begins to collapse tengan uzui
finds himself getting cornered between two of
guatara's attacks however tangero jumps in and
manages to protect him from these slashes tengen
proceeds to use sound breathing fifth form string
performance to try to corner guataro but daki's
obi interferes and protects her brother from the
attacks tengan begins to be pushed back by the obi
however tangent moves in to cut the obi and tries
to distract the otado the hashira is left amazed
at tanjiru's endurance despite suffering a serious
shoulder wound and realises that tanjunu had tied
his sword to his hand to prevent him from dropping
it due to his exhaustion meanwhile on the rooftop
zenitsu and unosuke can be seen struggling as
they try to evade the attacks from darki's obi
the boys realize that dhaki is now attacking
them with the blood blades used by guitar making
it impossible for them to approach her now that
the brothel has been destroyed tengan and tanjiro
are left to fight guatara and the ob beneath the
night sky on a nearby rooftop henatsuru appears
carrying a large box filled with kunai darts and
proceeds to launch dozens of them down below on
guataro at first he is left confused by the random
attack but then guitar uses his blood demon art
rampant art rampage to deflect them all away from
him guatara is left shocked though when tenkan
proceeds to attack him despite getting pierced
with the darts he attempts to decapitate him
with a sickle however tenkan manages to evade
his attacks and successfully cuts off his leg
at that moment guatara is struck on the neck by
one of the kunai darts and fails to regenerate
his leg realizing that the darts were coated with
a wisteria extract as his body begins to go numb
tangelo closes in on him to try to decapitate
guataro leaving him seething with curiosity as
the demon slayers quickly gained the upper hand
the kunai darts which were utilized by hinatsuru
were revealed to be coated in a poison which
would generally paralyze a demon for half a day
or possibly even immobilize a lower ranked demon
she can be seen on a nearby rooftop pleading for
the poison to work for even just a moment as
the demon slayers attempt to decapitate guataru
however at that moment guataru manages to
regenerate his legs and proceeds to attack them
at a close vicinity he uses his blood demon art
rotating circular slashes flying blood scythes to
emit numerous blood slashes to attack them before
they can reach him uzui grabs a hold of tanjuno
again and throws him back to protect him from
the attack within milliseconds tengan uses his
sound breathing form constant resounding slashes
to defect guatara's attack but finds that he has
disappeared from his side to his horror he looks
up to the roof to see that guatara has managed to
capture hinatsuru and is about to kill her tengan
tries to save her however darki's obi blocks him
from reaching her tenkin yells at guatara to stop
as he tries to push through tangido comes close to
the building and tries to use this hinokami kagura
to reach her however his body refuses to listen to
him tanjulo quickly change his tactics and uses a
form of water breathing to quickly save hanatsuru
from kyotoro realizing that he managed to save
hinasuru tanjiro decides to utilise both water
breathing as well as the hinokami kagura in order
to increase his attacking power guataro is left
surprised by tanjuro's unexpected maneuvers and
chases at him at that moment tengen comes behind
guataro and swings his blade akuotaro's neck
while openly yelling that he owes tanjido nearby
on a rooftop inosuke can see tengen move in as he
attempts to cut off guatara's head his frustration
grows as they continue to evade darki's attacks
instead of move in to try and decapitate her
zenitsu calls out to winosuke and explains that
in order to defeat them they need to make sure
that their heads aren't connected instead of
trying to decapitate the two simultaneously
anosuke stunned looks at zenetsu absolutely amazed
and calls him awesome after seeing the difference
in his personality compared to his usual demeanor
meanwhile tangido assists tenkan by also trying to
swing his blade down on guitar's neck however the
demon manages to use his sickles to hold both of
their attacks and attempts to absorb their blades
tengan uses his free arm to use his second blade
to pierce guataro but his quick reflexes allow
him to catch the tip of the blade in his mouth
since he neck guillotaro is about to unleash
more blood blades tengan tells tangier to hang
in there as hinatsuru yanks tanjiro away from
them allowing tengan to leap off the roof while
pulling the demon with him before he can leap down
to hell a voice can be heard telling them to watch
out as enosuke and zine to crash onto the roof
while fighting the obi inosuke and zinetsu asked
tanjiro for help in order to defeat daki and
agrees asking that they'll finish quickly in
order to help the tengen as well hinatsuru tells
the boys that she will hide quickly in order to
allow them to focus on the battle and disappears
as they face [ __ ] she gets excited when tanjido
joins their fight and informs his comrades that
they need a fast attack in order to cut her neck
anosuke realizes that she has slowed down and
decides to go first to attack as xenonsu agrees
with tangido to protect him from behind and oscar
proceeds to dash forward using beast breathing
8th fang explosive rush was inetsu and tangido use
thunder breathing first form thunderclap and flash
eight-fold and water-breathing third form blowing
dance respectively to protect inosuke from the
ob [ __ ] begins to crack under the pressure as
inosuke closes in on her and manages to draw both
of his blades on either side of her neck anoski
bruises his heels into the ground as he uses
his beast breathing sixth fang palisade bites to
effectively decapitate [ __ ] tangelo smiles with
joy as he witnesses inosuke leap and catch darky's
head in the air rejoicing and successfully cutting
off her head inosuke claims that they have to act
fast and keep her head separated from her body
anosuke quickly tries to escape with the head in
order to prevent her from reattaching it to her
body he tells the other boys not to worry about
him but to instead help tengan but before he can
even get to safety [ __ ] uses his hair to put
up resistance he manages to stop her resistance
though but before he can get away guatara appears
behind him and impales him through the chest
tangero looks on in horror as guataru grabs
darki's head while inosuke collapses to the
floor he then looks down onto the ground and is
once again horrified to see the tengen laying
bleeding and unresponsive on the ground zenetsu
tries to warn tanjido of the oncoming obi attack
but before he can escape the roof collapses
beneath him and tangero falls to the ground
seemingly buried beneath the rubble as he
falls unconscious he apologizes to everyone
and specifically neziko for losing the battle
in his dream niziko can be seen telling him to
stop apologizing for any faults in their lives or
feeling unworthy she reassures him that it isn't
his fault that their lives were ruined and tells
him that they'll work together to make a better
future for themselves nezuko begins to cry as her
body morphs from her human form to her demon form
as she pleads for him to never apologize for any
regrets and tells him she understands how he feels
tangible awakens from his dream and tries to
recollect his thoughts but before he gets up
guataro can be seen standing over him questioning
if he's still alive guardato takes it upon himself
to tell tanjido that ignoski was pissed through
the heart zenetsu was suffering and trapped
beneath the rubble and tengan's heart had stopped
due to the poison he proceeds to refer to all of
them as pathetic and asks tanjiro how the demon in
the box is related to him and responds by saying
that she is his youngest sister guatara begins to
laugh at tanjulo's pathetic attempt to protect his
younger sister and tells him he should be using
his hands before proceeding to break his fingers
as tanjoru withers on the ground in pain guataru
proceeds to berate him for his weaknesses and
pulls him by his hair he teases tangier and
tells him to try to decapitate him but instead
of attacking him he slaps his hand on a small
bag and hangs his head down a defeat believing
that he broke tangential spirit he reveals his
grand idea of offering tangero the opportunity
to become a demon for the sake of his sister
tanjiro suddenly looks up into the sky iguataru
asks him if he's been trying to hold back his
tears but to his surprise tanjiru responds that
he had been preparing for the moments his face
gets close to guatara's and tanjunu brings his
head down and headbutts him with a great force
momentarily stunning guataro daki screams at him
to get up but as his legs falter he looks down to
discover that a kunai has been lodged into his leg
he realizes that when tangero had looked down
he had opened a bear given to him by hinatsuru
which contained wisteria poison tanjunu manages
to stand back up while guitar remains paralyzed
and crouched before him tangier uses his remaining
strength to swing the blade down onto his neck as
he tries to force the blade down and through
tangero envisions himself in guitar's place
and he thinks that if he were in this situation he
would want his comrade to kill him before he could
live as a demon on a nearby rooftop [ __ ] can be
seen rushing to her feet at the sudden change of
events to try and help her brother but before
she can even get close to them zenitsu manages
to free himself from the rubble he attacks her
using thunder breathing first form thunderclap
and flash to bring her attention to him and then
uses god speed to attack her neck zenetsu pleads
with his blade to cut through her neck since
he was given the chance to escape the rubble
and attack her while guitaro was subdued tanjiru
continues to struggle to cut through guatara's
neck but before he can do so guitar manages
to emit his blood blades to repel his sword
tanjulo was knocked off balance as guatara regains
his footing causing them to re-engage in battle
guataru gains the upper hand and brings
his sickle down on tangier's neck however
at that moment tengan regains his consciousness
and protects him from the sickle despite being
severely poisoned and missing his left hand denkin
engages in the head-to-head combat with guitar
but remarking that he's perfected the musical
score technique it is revealed that his technique
allows him to analyze maneuvers of his opponents
and read them like notes on a piece of sheet music
however the poison had hindered his attacking
ability meaning that he can only defend guataro's
attacks guataro manages to land a powerful attack
to the left side of tengan's face resulting in
the loss of his eye and proceeds to stab tenkin
tangero yells out to tenkan after witnessing him
get stabbed but tengan orders him to ignore and
jump tanjido leaps into the air towards guatara
and attempts to decapitate him but is brutally
stabbed through the jaw by guatara's sickle
the demon begins panicking as they gain the
upper hand and tries pulsating his poison to kill
tanjuro however tanjulo proceeds to ensure through
the pain and swings his sword towards guatara
tangelo can be seen swinging his blade down on
guatara's neck despite the demon sickle passing
through his jaw his arm strength isn't enough to
slice through his neck so he resorts to forcing
his entire body to push through ignoring the
pain guitar notices the change in tangible scar
as he develops a demon slayer mark and his eyes
roll back in his head the change in his demeanor
proves to be too great as tanjiro's blade cuts
through guatara's neck causing him to panic
meanwhile daki can be seen resisting
zinetsu's attempt to decapitate her
she tries to use the obi to kill zinetsu at
close range beninosuke unexpectedly rushes
up revealing that he protected his heart from
being stabbed by rearranging all of his organs
he also reveals that the poison has no effect
on him at all since he was raised up in the
mountains before proceeding to assist zinitsu by
decapitating daki the three boys let out a roar
as they muster out their strength to slice the
demon's neck after the long battle sinetsu and
inosuke manage to decapitate [ __ ] up on the
rooftop while tanjudo can be seen decapitating
guatara simultaneously on the ground the heads
fall onto the ground and roll until they end up
face to face as guataro's body falls onto the
ground tengan notices something being emitted
from it and becomes alarmed meanwhile upon a
nearby rooftop suma hinatsuru and marchio have
arrived to witness the end of the battle as makio
begins to bicker with sumer over her behavior
hinatsuru notices something as a miss down on
the battlefield she looks down to see tangido
is struggling to breathe as he bleeds out from
his jaw while trying to slow down the poison
tangelo looks over at tengen who's sitting down
in front of him and yelling at him with a panicked
expression however tangero fails to comprehend his
sudden alarm as tengen looks at him with horror
under the night sky nezuko can be seen looking
down as her brother with a concerned expression as
tanjo begins to regain his consciousness he looks
around to see these destroyed buildings around him
niziko nudges her brother as a way of letting him
know that she was the one who saved him from the
destruction tangier attempts to get up to search
for the others but his legs give out from beneath
him and he collapses onto the ground he hears
someone calling out to him in the distance and
recognizes the voice as belonging to zenitsu and
is unexpectedly picked up and carried by nezuko
the pair move towards the source of the commotion
and discover zenitsu has awakened from his slumber
not remembering any of the events that had just
transpired he tells tanchito that he can hear
inosuke's heartbeat getting weaker and weaker
and points to him laying unconscious nearby
the siblings rush over to him and tangier attempts
to wake up in oscar but to his dismay he feels his
heart getting weaker tangita begins to panic and
thinks of exposing him to sunlight or sending a
crow to shinobu for help but realizes that
he doesn't have the time for either options
his tears begin to swell up as inosuke lays dying
before him but nezuko nonchalantly comes forward
and unexpectedly sets enosuke on fire tangido
looks amazed as he witnesses enosuke's poisoned
skin here right before his eyes and his comrade
suddenly awakes to announce he's hungry the three
rejoice at the fact that he's okay and embrace as
tangido begins to sob elsewhere on the battlefield
zuma begins to wail loudly pleading for
tengan to live after winning the battle
her co-wife makio begins to panic as she realises
the antidote they administered is not working to
remove the poison from his body and hinatsuru
begins to weep realizing that he doesn't have
much time to live tengan begins to relay his final
words to his wives but is interrupted by suma's
loud whales makio becomes enraged as soon as
overreactive cries and begins to pull by her hair
and shove rocks into her mouth to make her be
quiet while henatsuru tries to prevent them
from bickering in a comical fashion though tenkan
sits spectating at his wives while they continue
to bicker during his final moments as he slips
away he then realizes that he can no longer move
speak or do anything due to the poison but then
everyone momentarily pauses when neziko suddenly
appears next to tengan they proceed to stare
at her as she raises her hand and grabs him
before setting him on fire his wives look in
horror until sumer comically pulls niziko away
saying that it's too soon to cremate him to
this surprise tengan begins to speak again
and asks how it is possible that the
poison has been removed from his body
which brings relief to his wives tanjido subtly
explains that nezuko's blood demonard has somehow
managed to remove the poison from their bodies and
expresses his relief to know that tengan is safe
tengan tries to tell tanchiro to rest if not he
will die from his injuries the tanjuno informs
tengen that he needs to confirm that the demons
have been defeated before he can rest the siblings
proceed throughout the rubble in search of the
demons heads and come across a pool of blood
tangido pulls out an apparatus and decides
to collect the blood in order to be studied
once the blood has been collected tamiya's cat
mysteriously appears before tanjudo and he puts
it in the box to be delivered to tamiyo as the
siblings continue their search tangido smells
the scent of the demons and guides niziko towards
them when they arrive guitaro and daki can be seen
viciously arguing over their defeat their heads
begin to disintegrate as they blame each other for
losing the battle with guitar disregarding dhaki
for being useless [ __ ] retaliates by saying that
someone as ugly as guitaro cannot be considered
her relative which leaves tanjido looking at them
concerned about the hurtful words they are spewing
at each other daki and guitaro continue arguing as
their heads begin to disintegrate she starts
chastising her brother for being useless and
questions if they are even related guitar grows
angry at her comments and calls her a weakling
even regretting to protect her in the first place
he loses his temper and goes on to spew hateful
remarks such as mentioning that his life would
have been better off without her and wishing
that she'd have never been born causing darky's
eyes to well up with tears tanjido intervenes and
covers guatara's mouth saying that he doesn't
mean what he is saying and that they shouldn't
spend their final moments with each other arguing
daki begins to wail at tanjiru out of frustration
yelling at him to leave them alone and stop
lecturing them darky's head reaches its last
phases of its disintegration as she cries out
for her brother to save her saying that she
doesn't want to die guitar hopelessly watches as
her head dissolves away while still calling out
to him before he impulsively calls out to her
by her birth name ume as he reaches his final
moments guitar recalls his past as a human born
in the kirimise to a prostitute mother before she
died from syphilis his mother tried to kill him
many times even after his younger sister was born
due to his appearance and lack of hygiene the
young guy was bullied and detested by everyone
that he met things began to change though after
his sister was born as her beauty dismissed his
inferiority complex and he uses ugliness plus his
newfound fighting skills to become an efficient
debt collector however the good fortune would not
last long for the siblings when ume turned 13 she
blinded a samurai with a comb and was viciously
burned and buried alive for her crime having been
away on his job at the time guitar returned to
find her barely alive in a hole and he hugged
her body as she cling to life he cursed the gods
to return his sister for treating them cruelly
before he is attacked by the same samurai the
samurai slashes guataro from behind and a manager
there brazenly calls guatara a nuisance and a
brute for harassing the locals of the district
before expressing their pissy at having lost ume
as a courtesan before the samurai could finish
him off guataro viciously kills the manager and
berates the samurai for having a lavish lifestyle
before gruesomely killing him as well as guatorre
tried to find help for him and his sister
no one would help them due to their reputation
and circumstances he trudges on through the
street until he ultimately collapses and bleeds
out onto the floor as the snow begins to fall
the siblings lay on the floor dying until they are
discovered by one of the upper ranked demons who
offers to turn them into demons uetado unemantably
proclaims that he would become a demon again
no matter how many times that he is reborn wanting
to always bring fear as guataro the debt collector
guitar muses how dark he could have been if he
had raised her differently before taking note of
his surroundings a younger looking [ __ ] appeared
behind him disgusted with their current location
and wondering where the exit was the emaciated
man ordered her not to follow him anymore getting
angry when she would not comply a tearful [
__ ] apologized for her earlier cruel insults
stating that it was because she had not wanted to
accept that it was her fault that they had lost
when guotaro still refused to not let her come
with [ __ ] tackled him from behind stubbornly
refusing to ever let go vowing to always be his
little sister no matter how often they are reborn
and finally accepting her company guitaro carries
his little sister into the fire that awaits them
in the world of the living tanjiro and niziko
watches the last of the demon siblings dissolve
into the air tangier wonders if they made up
which niziko affirms elsewhere obernai iguro
attempts to praise tengen for his defeat of an
upper rank 6 but is disappointed to hear that
he beat such a low ranking member of the 12 kazuki
as well as lost his left arm and eye tengan states
his intention to retire as a shira but obani
refuses to accept this as there is already a
vacant hashera position and their lower ranks of
the demon corpse keep on dying without improving
tengan disagrees with this last point stating that
tanjido is definitely improving while obani is
surprised that he survived the fight elsewhere
kaguya yubashiki learns of the group's victory
and is elated but is stricken by
the complications of his illness
he states that his victory will have mass
consequences enough to ensure muzan's defeat
within their generation he then collapses into a
continuous bout of coughing over at the infinity
castle akasha ponder's howard summoning must mean
a member of the upper ranks has been defeated
akasa looks on with displeasure as the benue
demon plays her instrument and is greeted by one
of the upper ranked colleagues gyoko the potted
demon asks him how he's been after 90 years and
proclaims his insincere worry over akasa being the
slain upper rank han tengu corrects his colleague
as it had actually been 113 years since they
had last been summoned and expresses his concern
over the oddity and the unluckiness of the number
ignoring them akasa asks the by demon if muzin had
arrived the answer being no and then if the upper
rank one had arrived before she can answer though
doma places a hand on a kaza's shoulder asking him
to show some concern for his well-being as well as
he did not wish to see any of his precious buddies
die gyoku and doma exchange a small conversation
about gyoko's pot and doma's use of the pot that
gyoko had given him acaza demands that doma remove
his hand viciously punching him when he does not
immediately do so quickly recovering from the blow
doma pleasantly asks if kaza had gotten stronger
since they last met enraging the tattooed demon
the biwa demon finally relates that the upper rank
1 had been the first to arrive surprising akaza
who spotted his silent colleague kokoshibo
noted that he was present as was their master
as each upper rank reacted to the silent arrival
of their leader muzan noted that gyotaro was dead
doma apologized for kyataru's failure
wondering what punishment muzan would give him
but the ancient demon declined all of his
suggestions having already anticipated the upper
ranked sixth defeat he further commented that
he did not expect anything from him which doma
questioned as he did not believe that he had ever
failed to live up to his master's expectations
but mooz encountered by stating that the
uber yoshiki family had yet to be killed
and the blue spider lily had yet to be found
making him question why the upper ranks even exist
each of the upper ranks offer some excuse for this
failure save akaza and gyoko the latter offers
muzan some information that he claims will get him
closer to achieving his goals swiftly beheading
the upper rank muzam berates gyoko for speaking
of change as he is only looking for permanence he
adds that he is at the height of his displeasure
due to an upper rank being killed for the first
time in over 100 years further berating kyoko for
attempting to give him unconfirmed information
he demands that the upper ranks serve him with
suicidal devotion from that moment on he then
orders gyoko to head over with han tengu to
see if he can confirm this information and then
leaves doma then approaches goku asking to join
him on his mission and then in an instant has the
upper portion of his head completely destroyed by
a kaza akaza the upper rank 3 demon orders him to
get lost as muzan had not given him any specific
orders akasa looks in disbelief as his arm is
sliced off by kokushibo doma attempts to defend
his subordinate but kokushibo reprimands akaza
for his actions as they soil the relationships
between the upper ranks advising him to battle
doma for his spot as upper rank 2 instead if he is
truly bothered after hearing the suggestion doma
interrupts and asserts that akaza wouldn't be able
to raise his rank given how much more powerful he
was despite becoming a demon much later than him
a fact that likely contributed to acaz's rage
he continues on describing how he allowed akaza
to use violence on him as a way to get along with
him kokushibo ignores doma and asks zakaza if he
understood what he meant akaza confirms declaring
that he would definitely defeat him one day
receiving a word of good luck from his superior
as he leaves the fortress gomer tries to start
a conversation with akaza but he ignores him as
he exits gyoko then asks nakime to send him and
hantengu to their next destination and which the
bee were demon complies to she additionally sends
doma back to his cold when he tries to talk to her
after which he mopes over his colleague's
unfriendliness somewhere else a man is seen
sitting by a house with another individual sumi
yoshi brings some tea and some food the man
thanks his friend for the hospitality in which the
letter apologizes for his wife being asleep and
the child having to be babysat by a guest he tells
him not to worry about the situation and that he
shouldn't continue receiving the meals for free
from his friend sumi yoshi denies this revealing
that his family was saved by him and their lives
were thanks to him he also offers to pass down
his guest's tale as he didn't have any successes
even if his family were just simple coal burners
sumiyoshi is gently turned down by his friend
as he states that his heritage will find its way
back itself and that no matter what it will return
he then says that despite sumi yoshi viewing him
as powerful he was unable to protect what was
important to him and had little worth tangido
internally begs the man to not think of himself
like that and cries as he wakes up from the dream
heavily bandaged and hooked up to multiple
ivs he tries to figure out where he is and
is suddenly interrupted by falling vaz kano
stands in shock in the doorway and reveals
that tanjuro had been unconscious for two months
tearfully stating that she's glad he's awake
so well that finally brings us to the very end
of the entertainment district arc from the one
and only demon slayer this arc really is something
else out of what i've read from kamek suno yiber
this arc is definitely my favorite which is
why i've decided to start here when it comes
to covering the entire demon slayer story it's
absolutely awesome to see how much an improvement
all three of the young demon slayers have
especially zenitsu throughout this entire arc here
see now he was used as comedic relief and the
manga was absolutely hilarious like when he
gets left on the street by tengan and we find him
jamming out in the middle of i can't remember what
house it is but with his shamason i think that's
just absolutely hilarious and i love it compared
to his like anime version of zunitsu which i find
almost like a little bit more annoying so i i love
the the comparison that we get from anime to to
manga zunitsu here i thought i find him a lot
better so hope the uh the anime does take that
kind of like take with zenitsu and we do see a
more of like the funnier side of him this arc this
part of the manga takes place from chapter 70 and
goes all the way up to chapter 99 if you guys are
interested in starting the story and reading like
throughout the manga and all that kind of stuff so
if you do want to start from after this video then
chapter 100 would be like a good spot for you
guys to start from but if not like i do still
recommend that you guys read throughout the entire
arc just in case i've missed like a thing here
or there that you might find there's like vital
information later on throughout the entire story
and uh i might have just missed it if you have
enjoyed this video though then do feel free to hit
that subscribe button and also be sure to leave a
like on the video as it really helps out with the
algorithm and pushes my stuff to a bunch of new
amazing people plus i put a bunch of work into
these uh like longer explained videos especially
this one over the last three weeks i've put a
ton of work into like editing this video and
getting it out like on time and i keep having
to push things back but here it is now so if
you guys could uh hit that subscribe button i
would really really appreciate it i've also got
some merch if you guys are interested which i
will leave a link to like it down below along
with like my patreon and all my like discord
and that kind of stuff if you guys do want to join
or look at all that kind of stuff but anyway for
now it's been your professional degenerate
diavolo and i'll see you all in a bit bye
you